here is Teachers Union president this
woman my god oh
I was almost going to say something but
my mom's downstairs she made a request
this woman Randy Weingarten she's
running the teachers union she locked
kids in school she locked kids out of
school she masked kids she's just
absolutely terrible and she's a Democrat
activist pretending very poorly to be
nonpartisan she's also always going to
Ukraine which is a little bizarre to
talk about how important it is that we
help Ukraine because she's the teachers
union president here in the United
States anyway here she is in front of
the Supreme Court having a full-on
psychotic episode enjoy and frankly and
this is what really pisses me off during
the pandemic we understood that small
businesses were hurting and we helped
them and it didn't go to the Supreme
Court to challenge it fake businesses
were hurting and we helped them and it
didn't go to the Supreme Court to
challenge it all of a sudden what is
about our students
they challenge it the corporation's
challenges the student loan lenders
challenge that that is not right that is
not fair and that is what we are
fighting as well when we say castle soda
dead
you know guys
um one of the things I've really come to
believe in my old age is that if you
have a command of what you believe if
you know what you believe and why you
believe it and if you think through the
issues honestly and clearly even when
all hell is breaking loose and it always
seems like all hell is breaking loose
like you can communicate that kind of
clearly and honestly uh there are times
when I'm more annoyed right like you've
seen this show long enough we did that
clip a couple weeks ago where I just
dropped like eight f-bombs in one
sentence and I was genuinely like
frustrated but these fake emotive
pandering ridiculous LARPing actions by
these people they scream and this is
what progressives do they don't she
doesn't know why she believes what she
believes she just damn well wants it
done and why does she want it done
because she wants it done and that's
good enough that does not mean it is
constitutional lady and by the way you
were for all the closures you were for
closing the schools so now you pretend
you really care that small businesses
and big businesses were closed you were
for
all of it this woman has done more to
damage the minds and bodies of young
people in America maybe more than anyone
except for maybe I don't know Rochelle
wilinsky from the from the CDC
foreign
[Music]